in his book the greatest show on earth
the evidence for evolution Richard
Dawkins argues that denying evolution
today is comparable to denying the
Holocaust the New York Academy of
Sciences in New York City hosts this our
20-minute event we have a war on our
hands you've just heard that more than
40% of the US population according to
Gallup believes that the world came into
existence less than 10,000 years ago
that is a quite astonishing disconnect
from reality the reality is that the
world is 4.6 billion years old and I've
mentioned this calculation many times
before the equivalent of believing that
the world is only six thousand years old
which is the official biblical figure is
to believe that the distance from New
York to San Francisco is less than 80
yards that's the scale of the error that
we're talking about and it's an error
that if Gallup is to be believed is in
the minds of 44% of the American
population at the beginning of this book
I have likened the predicament of a
science teacher today to a Latin teacher
or teacher of Latin and Roman history
having to contend with a sort of
rearguard defense having to put out a
rearguard defense of the proposition
that the Romans existed at all and that
the Latin language was ever spoken
rather than being an invention to keep
Victorian school masters in in
employment
I've also likened the history denial
shown by these young earth creationists
to Holocaust deniers in the sense that
the evidence for evolution is as strong
as the evidence for the Holocaust I
hasten to say I'm not suggesting that
evolution deniers are motivated by
same sinister political agenda as
Holocaust deniers are they're motivated
by a different sinister political agenda
but I don't want to make this book seem
like a negative debunking kind of book
it isn't mainly that the evidence for
evolution is above all positive it's
enthralling it's exciting it's it is the
greatest show on earth life on this
planet is the greatest show on earth and
life on this planet may well be the
greatest show in the universe because we
have no evidence that anything like the
quite astounding phenomena of life are
to be found anywhere else in the
universe maybe they are in which case
life is the greatest show in the
universe still the first chapter also
considers the definition of the word
theory which as you know is much
misunderstood and I quote two
definitions from the Oxford Dictionary
one of which is the tentative only a
theory only a hypothesis that needs
falsifying or verifying and the other
being the sort of meaning that a
scientist uses when when talking about
say the heliocentric theory of the solar
system or the theory of gravitation or
the atomic theory of matter and it's of
course in that sense that evolution is a
theory but in ordinary colloquial
language evolution is a fact chapter two
dogs cows and cabbages follows Darwin in
making use of domestication the
astonishing power of selective breeding
to produce from a wolf dog or from the
wild cabbage Brassica oleracea all the
different varieties of cabbage like
plants that we eat cauliflower Brussels
sprouts broccoli and Vera sorts of
cabbage and so on if you wanted to do an
experiment to test the theory of natural
selection what would you do well
experiment implies human intervention
what you would do would be to administer
the Selective force yourself as an
experimenter in other words you would do
artificial selection which is what
humans have done inadvertently at first
reading dogs and cabbages and pigeons
and so on and also experimentally there
are numerous experiments where people
have administered a selective pressure
on populations of animals and plants and
produced dramatic results dramatic
evolutionary change in a very short time
within one human lifetime a nice example
is the work of B life Russian geneticist
who studied silver foxes and bred them
artificially for tameness and he
succeeded in breeding super tame foxes
which behaved like dogs licked your face
where their tail paved just like dogs
what's more interesting is that after
only about 30 years he has these foxes
that look like dogs they they look like
collie dogs no longer look like foxes
they've got black and white patches on
their coats they've got floppy ears
they bark like dogs that is a curious
phenomenon of traits being dragged along
in the wake of other ones he selected
only for tameness but what he got was
doglike characteristics and all sorts of
other respects an interesting side
glance the important point is that he
produced dramatic evolutionary change in
a mere 30 years if you can do that in 30
years
just think what could be achieved in a
hundred million years it would not be
artificial selection of course it would
be natural selection coming on to that
chapter three the primrose path to macro
evolution this chapter is an exercise in
seduction starting with artificial
selection which we've just been talking
about showing the power of artificial
selection
I'm trying gradually to wean the reader
on to natural selection by going through
a number of intermediate stages the
peahen selects the peak
in something like the same way as human
breeders select frisian cattle or white
lagoon hens peahens of course don't
consciously choose peacocks they do
choose peacocks on the basis of that
which appeals to them aesthetically can
use the word aesthetically and the
result is the astonishing flamboyant
splendour of the peacock the same thing
happens with birds paradise
numerous other birds insects fish
amphibians mammals and so on flowers the
brightness of flowers the bright colors
of flowers that the the exotic the
seductive perfumes of flowers these were
first of all chosen by insects
choosing the flowers that they would
visit to and and from the blast point of
view pollinate that's what the flower
gets out of it the insect gets nectar of
course usually what the insect started
human horticulturalists carried on with
so something like a wild rose pretty
little flower but nothing to compare
with the beautiful roses that human
gardeners have produced by artificial
selection the beautiful perfumes what
I'm saying what of the point the point
I'm making is that what humans electors
have done is simply to carry on where
the insect selectors left off so we can
regard insects as doing the same kind of
job as human artificial selectors angler
fish have a fishing rod sticking out of
the top of their head with a base on the
end and they play their prey small prey
down into the vicinity cast the rod down
into the vicinity of the mouth small
fish are attracted to the bait when they
get sufficiently close to the mouth the
angler fish opens up it's great more and
the inrush of water sucks in the prey
obviously a very sensible way to get
prey from the point of view of the
victim the prey fish you could say that
the prey fish are acting as selective
breeders selecting angler fish for more
effective
now obviously it's not to the advantage
of the prey to do that nevertheless that
is what they're doing so you see how the
Primrose pastures to macro-evolution the
seductive path is working I'm gradually
moving towards natural selection in
natural selection we've already got to
natural selection of course but in
ordinary natural selection we generalize
it and say that any any variation any
genetic variation whatsoever whether
it's visible on the outside as all the
examples I've talked about so far have
been or a purely internal change genetic
change some subtle detail of
biochemistry something that you'd never
notice on the outside at all if it
contributes in any way to the survival
or reproduction and/or reproduction of
the animal that will be positively or
negatively selected we've moved now up
the primrose path of seduction from
artificial selection which anybody can
understand which was understood of
course long before Darwin to natural
selection which only Darwin and Wallace
could it could be argued anyway really
grasped it was Darwin and Wallace who
saw the principle of artificial
selection that everybody understood
could be generalized to nature nature
just means that some animals survive and
some animals don't survive for whatever
reason and that has exactly the same
effect as if there was a human breeder
choosing which puppies to save and which
puppies to kill which puppies to breed
from which puppies not to breed from in
order to get major macro evolutionary
change such as changing fish into
mammals you need time artificial
selection we've seen that in human terms
in a few centuries we've seen what can
be done but in natural selection
evolution we've got hundreds of millions
of years we need to know how you'd set
out the evidence that we do have
hundreds of millions of years in
Darwin's time this was doubted Darwin's
time the senior British physicist of the
day Lord Kelvin demonstrated to the
satisfaction of himself another visit
that the Sun and the earth were only a
few million years old not long enough
for evolutionary change this worried
Darwin because he was a humble man and
he recognized as many of us do that
physics is kind of a senior science and
so he kind of he never actually caved in
but it did worry him it's the basis for
kelvins miscalculation was that he being
a Victorian scientists thought that the
Sun was was doing combustion was burning
something didn't really think it was
coal but something like um burning coal
in which case his calculation would have
been correct it's a nice quirk of
history that it fell to Charles Darwin's
son Sir George Darwin
Charles himself was never knighted his
son Sir George Darwin and to demonstrate
to the British Association in the early
20th century that the Sun because it was
a nuclear reactor had plenty of time to
have given all the time we need for
evolution what Darwin should have said
to Lord Kelvin is well if your physics
tells you that the earth is not old
enough for evolution to have taken place
then I'm sorry your physics is wrong
because the evidence from biology is
overwhelming that would have been the
correct response as it turned out it the
refutation came finally from from
physics my chapter mostly goes into the
details of how we know how old the earth
is how we know how old fossils are
mostly using a radioactive dating
physicists will tell us the half-life of
isotopes and these isotopes kids for
example potassium-40 decays to argon-40
with a half-life of 1.2 six billion
years at the moment when molten lava
solidifies crystals are formed and at
that moment you could say that the clock
is zeroed
the clock the potassium clock is zeroed
the argon-40 content is zero at any
later time if you measure the argon
conve argon-40 content of the
potassium-40 content and compare the two
knowing the half-life of this particular
decay you can calculate the exact moment
within ordinary limits of error the
exact moment when that crystal was
formed when that lava solidified fossils
don't appear in don't occur in igneous
rock so you have to look for igneous
rock that is to be found in the vicinity
of a fossil in sedimentary rock and
that's not too difficult to do and the
science of dating is now well developed
and it's how we know how old fossils are
and how we know how old the earth is 4.6
billion years that there are other ways
in which we know that as well the next
chapter before our very eyes I've said
that mostly evolution takes a very very
long time and there are exceptions to
that there are some cases where we see
natural evolution taking place
sufficiently fast that an individual
scientist can study it within one
scientific lifetime a matter of a matter
of decades and I discuss a number of
examples of this but they're fairly few
these examples compared with the
evidence that we have from the massive
amount of time that's been available for
long-term macro evolution and for that I
use the analogy it's a recurrent analogy
throughout the book over detective
coming on the scene of a crime too late
to be an eyewitness and this would be
the normal situation for a detective
it's not granted to many detectives to
actually be eyewitnesses to a murder
they come upon the murder afterwards and
they then look at clues which remain
fingerprints footprints bloodstains all
sorts of other things that are left
lying around and from this the detective
infers what must have happened the
equivalent for evolution is clues that
remain which hugely outnumber in in
number and strength
the clues that are available to any
detective in any ordinary murder mystery
so beyond reasonable doubt which is the
criterion that juries are supposed to
work to work to the evidence for
evolution is far beyond reasonable doubt
it's just beyond all possible
conceivable sane sensible doubt chapter
6 missing link what do you mean missing
creationists love the fossil record
because they think it's an embarrassment
to evolutionists because they point out
that there are gaps in the fossil record
well of course there are gaps in the
fossil record what do you expect would
you expect every single species has ever
lived to fossilize we're lucky to have
fossils at all if we didn't have a
single fossil if not a single corpse
that ever fossilized the evidence for
evolution would be utterly secure we
don't need fossils to demonstrate
evolution it's nice that we've got them
because they tell us a lot about the
history of life but we don't need them
to demonstrate that evolution is a fact
the evidence comes from other sources
the the biggest gap and one that
creationists love best of all is the gap
before the Cambrian era just over half a
million years ago before that time there
were rather few fossils and most of the
major animal phyla appear relatively
suddenly in the fossil record in the
Cambrian I wrote in an earlier book you
just read a passage
yes in the blind watchmaker in 1986 I
wrote the cambrian shows us a
substantial number of major animal phyla
already in an advanced state of
evolution the very first time they
appear it is although they were just
planted there without any evolutionary
history you can see how naive I was in
1986 not to realize how shamelessly that
would be quote mind
it's as though they were just planted
there without any evolutionary history
needless to say this appearance of
sudden planting has delighted
creationists I was savvy enough to
realize that they would like that I
decided to search the worldwide web for
that sentence it is although they were
just planted there without any
evolutionary history to see how many
hits I got and I obtained no fewer than
1250 hits for that sentence well you
need a control if you're a scientist to
compare that with otherwise you don't
know what you expect to get how many
hits you'd expect to get from from a
sentence like that so I looked at the
very next sentence from the blind
watchmaker which was evolutionists of
all stripes believed however that this
really does represent a very large gap
in the fossil record the number of hits
I obtained for that as compared to the
twelve hundred and fifty for the first
quote number of hits obtained for the
second quote was 63 the ratio of twelve
hundred and fifty to sixty three is
nineteen point eight and I call that
ratio the quote mining index the quote
mining index is also very high for the
famous quote from Darwin where he talks
about the eye and says something like to
suppose that the eye with all its he
goes into detail sentence about all the
highly complicated ways in which eyes
are adapted and adjusted and do self
focusing and self stopping down he says
to suppose that the eye could have been
formed by numerous small small
incremental changes seems absurd in the
highest degree if he then of course goes
on but that's where the quote stops
and they miss out Darwin's immediately
following explanation for how actually
although it seems absurd it's not absurd
and once again we have a very high quote
mining index the ratio
I've done it for that too the ratio of
the two of the number of hits of the two
quotas is also very high what is well
before leaving the Cambrian explosion I
just want to make one more point there
are modern animals for example flatworms
the great phylum platyhelminthes which
includes tapeworms and flukes and
free-living tur buleria which are
beautiful animals they're delightful
animals often very brightly colored very
ubiquitous very common enormously common
what more there are more species than
there are mammals for example not a
single fossil of a platyhelminthes has
ever been found or authentically found
in other words we have here a major
modern phylum which has no fossil
history at all it is as though it were
planted here yesterday so you see how
illogical it is to say that because
there are no fossils before a certain
point therefore there were no animals
there are all sorts of reasons why an
animal doesn't fossil it may be too
small it may be that it doesn't have
hard skeletal parts that's the case for
the flat worms for example
I'm going to read another short passage
from this chapter what would be evidence
against evolution and very strong
evidence of that would be the discovery
of even a single fossil in the wrong
geological stratum JBS Haldane famously
retorted when asked a name and
observation that would disprove the
theory of evolution fossil rabbits in
the Precambrian no such rabbits no
authentically anachronistic fossils of
any kind have ever been found all the
fossils that we have and there are very
very many indeed occur without a single
authenticated exception in the right
temporal sequence yes there are gaps
where there are no fossils at all and
that's only to be expected but not a
single solitary fossil has ever been
found before it could have evolved
that's a very telling fact and there's
no reason why we should expect it on the
creationist theory a good theory a
scientific theory is one that is
vulnerable to disproof yet is not
disproved evolution could so easily be
disproved if just a single fossil turned
up in the wrong date order evolution has
passed this test with flying colors
skeptics of evolution who wish to prove
their case should be diligently
scrambling around in the rocks
desperately trying to find anachronistic
fossils maybe they'll find one want a
bet
the next chapter carries on the theme of
fossils into human fossils
it's called missing persons missing no
longer and I'm going to read just a
little bit about the type specimen of
Australopithecus africanus which is the
so called torn child
Australopithecus was the genus that
almost certainly preceded our own genus
Homo in our evolutionary ancestry in
other words we're almost certainly
descended from members of the genus
Australopithecus although it may not be
any one of the species that have so far
been named the first australopithecine
to be discovered and the type specimen
of the genus was the so-called
torn child at the age of three and a
half the Taung child was eaten by an
eagle the evidence is that damage marks
to the eye sockets of the fossil are
identical to marks made by modern Eagles
on modern monkeys as they rip out their
eyes poor little torn child shrieking on
the wind as you were borne aloft by the
aquiline fury you would have found no
comfort in your destined fame two and a
half million years on as the type
specimen of Australopithecus africanus
poor tong mother weeping in the Pliocene
i want at this point to raise a point of
terminology which i think is extremely
relevant the Torn I said was the type
specimen of Australopithecus africanus
that means it's the specimen that was
first discovered and described and to
which people refer when they have a new
specimen and they want to know does it
belong to this species or not so each
new fossil or new animal indeed that's
that that's discovered is always given a
Linnaean binomial name a specific name
preceded by a generic name like Homo
sapiens Australopithecus africanus or
whatever it is
when a fossil is actually intermediate
between two species or two general and
on the evolution review there must be
such fossils we are not allowed by our
conventions of them of nomenclature to
give it an intermediate name there's no
machinery in in language to give a name
that is intermediate between say
Australopithecus afarensis and Homo
habilis yet if that there must have been
a member of the genus Homo that was the
immediate child of a member of the genus
Australopithecus but you can immediately
see that that's nonsense
because how could a baby be a different
genus from its from its mother obviously
in every single case every baby born is
the same species let alone the same
genus as its mother if you were to walk
backwards down through your ancestral
tree starting with your mother then your
grandmother great-grandmother let's just
stick to females for convenience
great-great grandmother and so on you
would go back and back and back and back
and back go back as far as you like and
gradually the animals that you that you
were walking past as you walk past your
ancestors would be gradually ever so
slowly changing into something else by
the time you got back to about 6 or 7
million years ago you would be looking
at an animal which was the common
ancestor between ourselves and
chimpanzees and you could then if you
wish turn around and start walking
forwards along the line leading to
chimpanzees at every single point along
that sequence the animals that you are
looking at would belong to the same
species as their their immediate
neighbors which would be their mother
and their daughter they would be more
alike than members of species ordinarily
are because they would because they
would be mother and daughter therefore
they would be more alike and yet if you
walk back sufficiently far they would
have changed from modern Homo sapiens to
a completely different genus
could go back to a fish using the same
technique and by the time you got to the
to the end of your walk he would have
walked through a continuously changing
set of animals all the way from human to
fish then he could walk forwards again
from fish to I don't know what I mean a
kangaroo or something in every single
case you would be would be seeing
animals that are of the same species as
their neighbors in the sequence and yet
the changes are so slow yet so
persistent that eventually you get back
to a fish it's not all that surprising
because after all when a baby turns into
an adult you don't suddenly say aha
it seems to be a baby it's now turned
into a child then our hearts not cease
to be a child has now become an adult
it happened so gradually you don't
notice the change if we're like a flea
sitting on the hour hand of a watch you
can't see it
you can't see it moving it moves so
slowly that you'd good but you don't see
it now in spite of that we do force upon
every fossil that we find by convention
the binomial name either say
Australopithecus afarensis or Homo
habilis and that's meat and drink to
creationists because whenever a fossils
found it's either an ape or a human we
don't have a name for an intermediate we
can't call it an intermediate because
when we don't have the nomenclature or
apparatus to do so and they prey on that
convention and maybe it's time
evolutionists started while never
actually abandoning the the Linnaean
binomial convention nevertheless admit
that there may be times when a fossil
doesn't deserve to be given a name
simply should be called intermediate
between some other recognized fossils
think about it another way if every
creature that had ever lived
fossilized then naming would be
impossible everything would be
intermediate you'd have to give it a
name that reflected the the shading
between species and general
the next chapter I'm just going to read
the beginning that irascible genius JBS
Haldane who did so much else besides
being one of the three leading
architects of neo-darwinism was once
challenged by a lady after a public
lecture
it's a word-of-mouth anecdote and john
maynard smith is sadly not available
to confirm the exact words but this is
approximately how the exchange went
evolution skeptic professor halt dein
even given the billions of years that
you say were available for evolution I
simply cannot believe it is possible to
go from a single cell to a complicated
human body with his trillions of cells
organized into bones and muscles and
nerves
a heart that pumps without ceasing for
decades miles and miles of blood vessels
and kidney tubules and a brain capable
of thinking and talking and feeling jbs
but madam you did it yourself and it
only took you nine months
that chapter is about embryology and the
important relationship between
embryology and evolution you can't
understand the evolution fully unless
you have some grasp of the embryonic
processes that generation after
generation start with a single cell and
give rise to an adult which then
reproduces producing a new single cell
and so on the processes of embryology
are extremely complex they themselves
must have evolved and that that chapter
is aimed at that understanding the next
chapter the arc of the continents is
about the geographical distribution of
animals and plant species in the islands
and continents of the world which coming
back to our detective analogy are
exactly what you would expect them to be
if they had evolved and exactly what you
would not expect them to be if they had
been created especially if they had been
released from Noah's Ark I'll read a
short paragraph or two from that chapter
it's almost too ridiculous to mention it
but I'm afraid I have to because of the
more than 40% of the American population
who as I lamented in Chapter one accept
the Bible literally think what the
geographical distribution of animals
should look like if they'd all disbursed
from Noah's Ark shouldn't they be some
sort of law of decreasing species
diversity as we move away from an
epicenter perhaps Mount Ararat I don't
need to tell you that is not what we see
why would all those marsupials ranging
from tiny pouched mice through koalas
and bill bees to giant kangaroos and
Diprotodon
why would all those marsupials but no
placentals at all have migrated on mass
from Mount Ararat
to Australia which route did they take
and why did not a single member of their
straggling caravan pause on the way and
settle in India perhaps or China or some
Haven along the Great Silk Road why did
the entire order identity' all 20
species of Armadillo including the
extinct giant armadillo all six species
of sloths including extinct giant sloths
and all four species of anteater troupe
of unerringly for South America leaving
not a rack behind leaving no hide nor
hair nor armor plate of settlers
somewhere along the way why did all the
Penguins undertake the long waddle south
to the Antarctic not a single one to the
equally hospitable Arctic once again I'm
sorry to take a sledgehammer to so small
and fragile and not that I have to do so
I have to do so because more than 40% of
the American people believe literally in
the story of Noah's Ark we should be
able to ignore them and get on with our
science but we can't afford to because
they control school boards they
homeschool their children to deprive
them of access to proper science
teachers and they include many members
of the United States Congress some state
governors and even presidential and vice
presidential candidates they have the
money and the power to build
institutions universities even
Museum where children ride life-size
mechanical models of dinosaurs with
saddles which they are solemnly told
coexisted with humans we can't afford to
be snooty in Britain about that
twenty-eight percent of the British
population get their science from the
Flintstones as well
believing that humans coexisted with
Dinosaurs the next chapter the tree of
cousinship here I think we come to
perhaps the most powerful evidence of
all for evolution looking at the
enormous numbers of modern species that
there are and comparing them
systematically Darwin was able to do
this with Anatomy skeletons for example
he was able to see that the hand of a
man and the wing of a bat are directly
homologous and bat swing is enormous Li
long splayed out fingers with webbing
stretched between the fingers a horse's
hoof is the same hand where over the
five fingers only the middle one remains
and the horse walks on the middle finger
and the middle toe and the hoof is the
is the nail you can see that you can see
it in the fossil record how the number
of fingers diminished and there are
occasional free courses which are born
with three toes showing an intermediate
stage but that was the limit of what was
possible in in in Darwin's time you
could compare anatomy and show very very
convincing you that it fell on a family
tree nowadays you can do the same thing
with molecules with genes molecularly
analyzed and the sheer amount of
information available is multiplied many
orders of magnitude because the genetic
code is universal all creatures have the
same machine code the same code whereby
Triplets of DNA are rendered into amino
acids you can directly compare the same
gene in one animal with the same gene in
another animal you know it's the same
gene it's got essentially the same
sequence with minor differences there's
a lesser different
here less are different they're less are
different there and the corresponding
differences appear in the amino acids
and in the protein chain that they
produce but you could say this is the
same gene it's doing the same job it's
got the same sequence with these minor
differences and then you can literally
count the number of differences between
these genes it's not a case of saying oh
this limb looks a bit like that limb you
are literally comparing alternative
texts just like alternative versions of
the book of Isaiah or something where
you just look at count the number of
differences that there are between
chapters between letters between
sentences words and when you do that for
any one gene you like you find that the
difference is four on a beautiful
hierarchical tree what could that be but
a family tree what could that be but a
pedigree then you do the same thing for
another gene and you find the same tree
and then you do it for another gene and
you find the same tree then you do it
for a gene which no longer does anything
but you can still sequence it nature
doesn't read the gene anymore it's never
translated into protein but molecular
geneticists can read it and they can
recognize that it is a defunct version
of the same gene and again when you
compare these pseudogenes
you find the same family tree
there are minor exceptions to that but
in general it's it's dramatically true
that if you look at different genes you
find they fall on the same tree what
could that tree be but a family tree the
only alternative is that the intelligent
designer that the Creator deliberately
set out to deceive us and make it look
as though evolution had happened when it
didn't that's not a resort that I think
many theists would wish to cling to
next chapter history written all over us
when you look at modern animals you
don't need to look at fossils just look
at modern animals and you can see their
history written all over them look at a
dolphin look at a whale it's a purely
aquatic animal lives only in the sea but
you can tell from looking at it that it
has all the hallmarks of a land mammal
it's descended from a land mammal our
bodies any animal's body has mistakes
which no designer would ever have
perpetrated and yet which clearly are
understandable if you think historically
if you think this is descended from an
ancestor which did things differently I
was privileged to be attendant I
supposed to be the right word on a
deception of a giraffe's neck a few week
a few months ago while I was writing the
book in fact and we were dissecting the
recurrent laryngeal nerve of this
giraffe which it unfortunately died in a
zoo the recurrent laryngeal nerve is one
of the it's a branch of one of the
cranial nerves it starts with the in the
brain and it its end organ is the larynx
the voice box so you might think that if
a designer had made this nerve he would
have made it go straight from the brain
to the larynx which is what most nerves
do this nerve however goes right past
the larynx way down into the chest loops
around one of the main arteries in the
chest different one on different sides
and then goes back up to the larynx in a
human that's a detour of a foot or so in
a giraffe it's a detour of 15 feet or so
I watched this nerve as it was being
dissected out it'd go it goes within an
inch or so of the larynx and it goes
straight past it and then goes on south
on and on and on and on down into the
chest turns around and goes back up
again no designer it is senses would
ever have done that
yet it makes perfect sense when you
think of it historically when you look
back to the fish ancestors of mammals
where that nerve was doing something
very different and the most direct route
to what was then its end organ was
indeed posterior to the artery that
we're talking about
then when mammal neck started when fish
don't have necks when mammal neck
started to elongate the it wouldn't it
might have been possible to loop the
nerve over so that it went north of the
artery said of south of the artery but
in fact what happened was that the MU
its just stayed along gating as the neck
lengthened the marginal cost of
elongating the detour was so slight
compared to just the enormous cost of
what probably would have been an
enormous cost of changing the embryo
logical changing the embryonic processes
in order to completely reroute the nerve
into what would be a more economical way
of doing it the marginal cost was slight
just another millimeter what's another
millimeter evolution happens gradually
just elongated a bit more human
designers intelligent designers of all
kinds go back to the drawing board when
they when they've got a new design when
the jet engine when the jet plane was
invented when the jet engine was
invented does the designer of the first
jet engine started with a clean drawing
board he didn't start with a propeller
engine and then modified Rivet by rivets
screw by screw not by not which is the
equivalent of the way evolution has to
work imagine what a jet plane would look
like if it was a gradually step-by-step
modified propeller plane that's what
that's the limitation under which
evolution is working given that it's
amazing that animals work so well the
reason they work so well has despite
these bages these bungles as we would
look at as an engineer would call them
evolution natural selection is a
brilliant tinkerer that comes along
afterwards and makes corrections
after the event so for example with the
with the vertebrate retina in the eye
which is back to front once again what
an atrocious piece of bad design that is
the photo cells that are detecting the
light of facing backwards and the wires
that connect them to the brain are in
front in the way of the light and they
have to dive through the retina in the
so called blind spot what designer would
ever have done that yet we see very well
because natural selection makes up for
the initial barge by superb tinkering of
detail which means that we end up seeing
very well arms races and evolutionary
theater see chapter 12 the evolutionary
arms race I think is a very important
and interesting idea
animals become adapted to their
environment but if the environment is
the inanimate environment like the
weather say an Ice Age comes and then a
drought comes and then a flood comes and
something else comes the evolution of
the animals just tracks the
environmental change weather when the
cold weather comes they get shaggy a
coats when the cold weather goes the
coats become less shaggy this all
happens in evolutionary time but what if
it's not the weather we're talking about
but predators predators are actually
getting better at being predators
because they're evolving to on the other
side prey animals are getting better at
getting away from predators so unlike
the weather which is maybe unpleasant
but it's not deliberately out to get you
predators are and prey animals are
deliberately out to get away from you
and they're getting better at it
and so in evolutionary time we see an
arms race where the Predators get a bit
faster at running and the prey animals
have to get a bit faster and the
Predators get faster it goes on
escalating until now you see superb
feats of speed by cheetahs of leopards
on the one side and by gazelles
antelopes
zebras American antelopes on the other
hand on the on the other side and when
you look at any beautifully designed
apparently designed piece of biological
machinery like an eye or an or a knee
joint fast-running leg and efficiently
pumping heart that goes on for a long
time what you're looking at is the end
product of an evolutionary arms race of
several evolutionary arms races run in
evolutionary time not to be confused
with the race that's run in real time
between an individual leopard and an
individual antelope so the arms race is
a race to improve the equipment for
survival this is an economical shift
it's got to be an economic shift into
the weaponry of the arms race whether
it's long running legs or sharp teeth or
keen eyes whatever it is from something
else in the economy of the body because
the body is a very thrifty economy has
to be like for example making milk if
only the leopards and the antelopes
could come to some kind of trades union
agreement but they're not they're not
going to that they would say the
antelopes are going to send a tithe of
their number to be eaten each each year
then neither side would have to develop
fast running limbs at all they could
just get on with the business of
reproduction everybody would be better
off but of course that's not how
evolution works evolution works at the
individual level I'm going to read a
little bit about arms races
one thing about arms races that might
worry enthusiasts for intelligent design
is the heavy dose of futility that loads
them down if we're going to postulate a
designer of the cheetah
he has evidently put every ounce of his
designing expertise into the task of
perfecting a superlative killer one look
of that magnificent running machine
leaves us in no doubt the cheetah if we
are going to talk design at all is
superbly designed for killing gazelles
but the very same designer has equally
evidently strained every nerve to design
a gazelle that is superbly equipped to
escape those very same cheetahs for
heaven's sake whose side is the designer
on when you look at the Cheetahs taut
muscles and flexing backbone you must
conclude that the designer wants the
cheetah to win the race but when you
look at the sprinting jinking dodging
gazelle you reach exactly the opposite
conclusion does the designers left how
not know what his right hand is doing is
he a sadist who enjoys the thrill who
enjoys the spectator sport and is
forever upping the ante on both sides to
increase the thrill of the chase did he
who made the lamb make thee is it really
part of the divine plan that the leopard
shall lie down with the kid and the lion
eats straw like the Ox in that case what
price the formidable car nacio teeth the
murderous claws of the lion and the
leopard whence the breathtaking speed
and agile escapology of the antelope and
the zebra
needless to say knows that problems
arise on the evolutionary interpretation
of what is going on each side is
struggling to outwit the other because
on both sides those individuals who
succeed will automatically pass on the
genes that contributed to their success
ideas of futility and waste spring to
our minds because we are human and
capable of looking at the welfare of the
whole ecosystem natural selection cares
only for the survival and reproduction
of individual genes
now finally the last chapter is called
there is grandeur in this view of life
which you'll recognize as a quotation
from Darwin it comes from the very last
paragraph of the Origin of Species and
my last chapter takes each sentence of
Darwin's last paragraph and makes each
sentence into a section heading of my
last chapter and the body of the section
is an exegesis of that sentence of
Darwin the last sentence of Darwin's
book is endless forms most beautiful and
most wonderful have been and are being
evolved and I'm going to read the last
page of the book in conclusion the fact
of our own existence is almost too
surprising to bear so is the fact that
we are surrounded by a rich ecosystem of
animals that more or less closely
resemble us by plants that resemble us a
little less and on which we ultimately
depend for our nourishment and by
bacteria that resemble our remoter
ancestors and to which we shall all
return into Kay when our time is passed
Darwin was way ahead of his time
in understanding the magnitude of the
problem of our existence as well as in
tumbling to its solution he was ahead of
his time too in appreciating the mutual
dependencies of animals and plants and
all other creatures in relationships
whose intricacy staggers the imagination
how is it that we find ourselves not
merely existing but surrounded by such
complexity such elegance such endless
forms most beautiful and most wonderful
the answer is this it could not have
been otherwise given that we are capable
of noticing our existence at all and of
asking questions about it it is no
accident as cosmologists point out to us
that we see stars in our sky there may
be universes without stars in them
universes whose physical laws and
constants leave the primordial hydrogen
evenly spread and not concentrated in
but nobody is observing those universes
because entities capable of observing
anything cannot evolve without stars not
only does life need at least one star to
provide energy stars are also the
furnaces in which the majority of the
chemical elements are forged and you
can't have life without a rich chemistry
we could go through the laws of physics
one by one and say the same thing of all
of them
it is no accident that we see dot dot
the same is true of biology it is no
accident that we see green almost
wherever we look it is no accident that
we find ourselves perched on one tiny
twig in the midst of a blossoming and
flourishing Tree of Life no accident
that we are surrounded by millions of
other species eating growing rotting
swimming flying walking burrowing
stalking chasing fleeing outpacing
outwitting without green plants to
outnumber us at least ten to one there
would be no energy to power us without
the ever escalating arms races between
predators and prey parasites and hosts
without Darwin's war of nature without
his famine and death there would be no
nervous systems capable of seeing
anything at all let alone of
appreciating and understanding it we are
surrounded by endless forms most
beautiful and most wonderful and it is
no accident but the direct consequence
of evolution by non-random natural
selection the only game in town the
greatest show on earth thank you very
much
I'm very happy to take questions I think
that this might need turning on no yeah
yeah okay so I think there are
intelligent designers at work they're
called molecular biologists and I was
wondering if what you think the
implications are for the course of
evolution of our ability to modify
plants and animals and us eventually
intelligent designers have been around
for a long time of course long before
molecular biologists because it was
intelligent designers who've made
Brussels sprouts and Pekinese is and and
and domestic roses so all that's new is
that instead of only having control over
the selection part of the Darwinian
process we now have control over the
nutation part as well
we can cause genetic changes whereas
before we simply had to wait for them to
happen so that's that is a big
difference and it is already making
having dramatic impacts on our control
over the evolutionary process but it's
been we've had a fairly good control
over it for a long time starting with
inadvertent control and moving on to the
more systematic and deliberate control
of scientific agriculture and
horticulture and and plant and animal
breeding a lot of scientific innovations
have led to a better understanding of
non anomalies and discrepancies for
example the general Ralph's relativity
finally explained the description is
that mic on it yes well sorry I'm not
close enough sorry I was that again um a
lot of scientific innovations have led
to a better understanding of anomalies
and discrepancies for example the
general theory of relativity led to a
better understanding of the
discrepancies of Mercury's orbit with
plenty of anomalies left in science such
as dark manager dark matter dark energy
the pioneer normally lucid theory of
everything thank you sir what
discrepancies do you think would lead to
if we investigated them more would lead
to a better understanding of evolution
that's a very interesting question I
think that particular model of the
history of science works very well for
physics it's not easy to see quite how
it would work in in evolutionary science
I suppose you might say that the theory
of punctuated equilibrium could be
regarded as an example of that where the
the discrepancies that were observed
were apparent departures from the
expectation of gradualness towards the
view that the apparent gaps in the
fossil record might not be be actual
gaps it might actually really represent
a genuine punctuation if event I don't
favor that theory as much as some people
do I think it probably works in some
cases anyway I don't need to go into
that now and that might be one possible
example there probably might be others
I'd need to think about that thank you
thank you thank you for an engaging talk
i Darwin consider changing the term
natural selection to natural
preservation we've ever read in a letter
his what would be the implication to the
greatest show on earth with the concept
of natural preservation over selection
Darwin was was worried and Wallace was
even more worried by the implications of
the word selection which seemed to many
people to imply deliberate selection I
mean the word selection I think that's
the problem and this was why Wallace
urged Darwin to adopt Spencer's term
survival of the fittest which again is
like natural preservation it's it
conveys a more passive view of the
process Wallace said that to him and to
Darwin himself the idea of natural
selection was as plain as daylight but
to many people it was not unto many
people and is done doubtedly true that
in Victorian times people did think that
there had to be some kind of selector
they just couldn't quite grasp the idea
that it really was just preservation it
really was just the survival or
the fittest I am not sure that many
people have that problem now I think
people have have other problems now
survival of the fittest gave rise to all
sorts of other confusions which which I
think are even greater than the
confusions that the Victorians saw in in
natural selection I do defender do you
think life has a natural tendency to get
more complex with time order it's just
random like if we all go extinct in
under million years and other
intelligence pieces will show therefore
right so I don't think it'd be right to
talk about an intrinsic tendency to get
more complex it probably is true that
natural selection under the right
conditions and I think especially of
arms races will make it things get more
complex there's no law that it has to
get more complex there are in parasites
of the famous case where they tend to
get less less complex so there's no
drive to become more complex
there's no urge to become more complex
but when you have predators chasing prey
and prey running away from predators
then you tend to get more complexity to
a prodigious extent I mean the
complexity of of of among one mammal or
indeed a bird or reptile is gigantic and
I think you could largely put that down
to UM competitive arms races with with
enemies but it's not an internal drive
to get more complex evolution and
natural selection seems so elegantly
simple especially compared to volatility
or quantum theory someone in forever
surprised that it took until the 19th
century for the surprises me hugely and
when I compare what Darwin achieved to
what Newton achieved two centuries
earlier it seems to me that what Darwin
achieved should have been a doddle
compared to what Newton achieved and yet
it took two centuries longer and I've
often wondered what it was that made it
so difficult to get it you certainly
don't need to be a mathematician
get it it came independently to two
English traveling natural ists it would
it evaded great thinking philosophers
and mathematicians down the ages anybody
could have thought of the idea from an
armchair from the time of the Greeks
onwards they never did or not properly
Ernst Meier who died only a couple of
years ago the age of a hundred thought
that the stumbling block was what he
called essentialism philosophical term
which conveys the idea that animals and
plants are have a kind of essential
haven't have an essence which is as
fixed and unalterable as for example the
essence of a triangle triangle and it
comes from the Greeks who were geometers
at heart and a triangle is a figure with
a fixed definition a triangle is a
triangle as a triangle it's a it's a
polygon with three sides and people seem
to see rabbits and rhinoceroses as
though they were triangles and incapable
of changing into anything else it's not
clear to me why they should have thought
that but that wasn't that's Myers
diagnosis the people could see how you
could get kind of minor changes within
rabid kind but the idea of extrapolating
those minor changes until a rabbit
turned into something quite different
you no longer call a rabbit even a fish
turning into a human after a sufficient
length of time that's them to be beyond
people maybe because the share time it
takes is greater than people can grasp
we're so used to the idea that rabbits
or rabbits that we don't live long
enough to see them turn into anything
else but it is it's a real mystery why
the achievement of Darwin which seems so
simple took so much longer or maybe it
was that the achievement of Darwin which
was to show that you can get from
without any design at all that you can
produce structures so complex that it
seemed like utter and complete common
sense they must have had a designer
maybe that is so far from common sense
that it that people who had the in
to do what Darwin did just it just
wouldn't even occur to them to even
doubt the possibility that something as
complicated as a brain or an eye or a
heart could have had no designer excuse
me
so lateral gene transfer is challenges
your ideas that all genes in the same
organism have the same history and
creationists have been using this to say
well since we can't know the true Tree
of Life that obviously something's wrong
and I'd wonder if you could address that
and when you were going to address that
in a book of yours um there was a an
issue of New Scientist which appeared
earlier this year with the dramatic
headline Darwin was wrong you can
imagine how the creationists used that
it turned out if you actually read the
article that it was nothing to do with
Darwin being wrong what it was about the
lateral gene transfer what it was about
was that in some organisms almost all of
them microorganisms bacteria genes move
sideways they don't stay in longitudinal
images like they do in mammals and birds
and most of the larger creatures that
Darwin himself was from was familiar
with now it is true that if you look at
bacteria you no longer get the nice
simple rule that says every gene comes
down from parents grandparents
great-grandparents
great-great-grandparents and so on
because we have that rule in the animals
we're familiar in plants that we're
familiar with the the tree of life is a
simple branching tree it never meets
branches once they've separated once the
species has split into two and there's a
little bit of a sort of fudge going on
while they're splitting when some kind
of crossbreeding becomes possible is as
possible remains possible once they
split sufficiently far apart they no
longer interbreed and there is never
again any lateral gene transfer from bit
from then on the tree of life goes on
branching and branching and branching
without any anastomosis without any
networking without any
crossing over that's not true of
bacteria in that area they promiscuously
and liberally adopt a kind of copy and
paste policy with respect to genes bits
of genome are just simply copied from
one bacterium and pasted into another
one with abandon and so it's true that
at the the root of the tree of life
where we have bacteria it's as I think
down then it's said it's more like a
banyan tree than than an oak tree it's
it's got um and massively crossing gene
gene transfer so you've got to do a
special trick when you get to the
bacteria you no longer think of
individuals as gene machines that are
struggling to pass on their genes
longitudinally down through the
generations
however the the idea of The Selfish Gene
still works a treat The Selfish Gene is
simply trying to maximize its own
propagation into the future and if it
can do it by copying and pasting itself
into another bacterium so much the
better so not only was Darwin not wrong
because Darwin didn't know about
bacteria Dawkins wasn't wrong because at
the level of The Selfish Gene if this is
that this is a happy hunting ground for
selfish genes is is dashing around from
from bacterium to bacterium like
Quicksilver that's wonderful stuff for
the for The Selfish Gene yeah um I have
100 questions but I just limited to one
so I read the New York Times review of
your book by Nicholas Wade and he
actually took you to task of it largely
a positive review but he took you to
task for asserting that evolution is a
fact and as a technical point he made an
argument that it's a theory and then
actually accused you of um having a not
sure if I get this right but I think
it's a lack of appreciation
native nature of science yeah which is
um I was insulted for you but yes
Nicholas Wade was was I have to say very
unfairly treated by the commenters to my
website Richard Dawkins dotnet where we
first it was he really got a bit of a
drubbing there um it I think it boils
down to the difference between what
philosophers of science say where you
wouldn't wish to say that anything was a
fact I mean he would you would wish to
say that that everything that we
ordinarily call a fact is just a
hypothesis that hasn't been disproved so
it is not a fact that the world is round
and not flat it is a hypothesis that has
never been disproved now as Stephen Jay
Gould said there does come a point where
that kind of countering to philosophy of
science needs to sort of merge into a
bit of common sense and the way he put
it was there comes a point where become
simply perverse to say well we're still
waiting to see if this hypothesis is
going to be disproved the hypothesis
that the world is round and not flat is
never going to be disproved and the same
I would maintain is true of evolution so
while it's while it's right to say that
philosophers of science would prefer not
to use the word fad because the word
theory is so wantonly misunderstood by
laypeople egged on and abetted by
creationist propaganda we are better off
using a word that ordinary laypeople
understand such as fact because we're
using the word fact in exactly the same
way as for example a court of law would
use the word fact if a lawyer wagged his
finger at you and said is it or is it
not a fact that you were in New York on
the night of September the 24th you
would not say well it's a hypothesis
that's difficult to disprove or
something about you would you would
answer the lawyer would have you on
toast if you said something like that
you would have to answer either it's a
fact or it's not a fact that's the sense
in which evolution is a fact the same
was the fact that I'm standing at a at a
wooden lectern in New York City
hi um it seems like we're making good
progress as a species in a society or
not we don't think that they're at the
center of the universe and we're not
like using leeches anymore the tree
people well some people but in each
other coming back and in our country you
know we're moving towards being allowed
to do stem-cell research but at the same
time we've got like Sarah Palin and like
we had a president who said that the
jury was out on evolution so do you
think that we really are moving in the
right direction over all now these
things just sort of setbacks that we
shouldn't lose yes I do think that's a
good word I think what we have is a is a
is a progressive movement which is not
steady but has a kind of sawtooth if
effect to it there's politics going on
here of course when something like the
Sarah Palin phenomenon is probably not
really about scientific truth is
probably about political what should we
say grievances maybe there's a sort of
inferiority complex among people who
don't have a very good education against
people who do I suspect there may be
something like that going on here but I
am enormous ly encouraged as I go around
the country and I tend to make a point
of going to places not like New York I
mean I tend to go to places which are
the so-called Bible Belt and I'm hugely
heartened by the warmth of the reception
that I get in places like Oklahoma and
Kansas and Alabama great big crowds
cheering and I think that's because they
feel beleaguered I think it's because
they they find that somebody coming in
from the outside who can say what he
likes but he's flying out on the next
plane
and yet and they hear somebody
articulating what they feel
but perhaps are intimidated from saying
because they don't want to be ostracized
at the golf club or or whatever it might
be
and people say that to me in the book
signing queue over and over again they
thanked me for kind of saying thank you
for coming to Kansas we need it we
needed somebody to say what what what
you've just said this is what I feel and
they suddenly notice a whole lot of
other people in the hall thousands in
some cases and they recognize that
they're surrounded by people
mitah be there in a minority but but
they can see that they're not alone and
I think that's leading to a change I
think you see it only on the Internet
I think it may be leading to a sort of
critical mass phenomenon whereby once
the the numbers of such people grow
beyond a certain point it will suddenly
go and you'll suddenly notice a dramatic
change this is less of a a biological
question more of a philosophical one but
I think there's a biological slant to it
so do you subscribe to the theory of
determinism or do you think there's any
biological evidence that educates free
well in humans or animals determinism in
the in the philosophical sense of
whether every event that happens in the
in the universe indeed is determined and
in principle predictable from earlier
events is not a question which a
biologist needs to answer separately
from philosophy or physics this is a
more general question physicists may
answer using the idea of quantum
indeterminacy and that might be relevant
to biology if quantum indeterminacy
effects biological events such as
whether at whether or not a nerve cell
fires at a particular moment or not I
don't have the expertise as a
philosopher to say whether it is right
that all events in the universe are
predetermined by
by other events and certainly being a
biologist doesn't give on any right to
to make such a thing what I can say as a
biologist is that the the idea of
genetic determinism which is a much more
restricted meaning of the word
determinism the idea that everything
about us is determined by our genes is
not justified by the facts and is
nothing whatever to do contrary to many
critics nothing whatever to do with the
theory of The Selfish Gene the theory of
The Selfish Gene has been widely
misunderstood as a deterministic as a
genetic deterministic theory
misunderstood by those many people who
have omitted to read the rather large
footnote to the title of The Selfish
Gene which is the book itself hi dr.
Dawkins I was a great talk my question
also was a little bit philosophical as
specifically the extension of evolution
beyond biology into a term you coined
than an idea that's often attributed to
you and that's mimetics it seems like
you've been a little from what I've read
a little bit hesitant to endorse the
idea I know you're not you know you're
not you're not against it or anything I
read your forward and susan blackboards
book but I was wondering if you had what
reasons you had or why you were such a
proponent my hesitancy is just that I
was never intending to offer a theory of
human culture that would have been
presumptuous coming from a biologist
what I was trying to do at the end of
The Selfish Gene was to downplay the
importance of the gene as the only unit
of natural selection the whole of the
rest of the book emphasized the gene of
the unit of natural selection because
genes do have certain very important
properties namely high fidelity self
replication and a powerful influence
over the world which affects their own
probability of being
replicated namely through phenotypes and
so in ordinary biology you cannot do
Darwinian theory without talking about
genes however a generalization of
Darwinian theory such as might take it
to other planets for example would look
for any kind of self-replicating
information which had those same
properties of high fidelity coupled with
the ability to exert power over the
probability of self replication and I
speculated that on other planets if
there is life it will be Darwinian life
but it probably won't be DNA based life
it will probably be some other kind of
self-replicating coded information and
then I suggested to make it easy to
understand maybe we don't need to go to
other planets maybe we've got one
staring us in the face on this planet
and that was where memes came from maybe
the sort of soup of human culture which
is all our brains interacting with each
other and passing information when we
copy when we imitate when when
information flows from one brain to
another is it possible to identify units
of information being transferred which
have high fidelity and which perhaps
have power over there their probability
in this case being imitated being and I
think they are I mean I mentioned things
like tunes that people whistle in the
street and that other people pick up you
catch it like a virus and you and you
hear this damn tune and it goes round
your head and you can't get rid of it
and so you whistle it on somebody else
hears it and he was loaded on somebody
else hears it and whistles it and it
will spread through it through a whole
lot of lot of people and the same could
be true of all kinds of things clothes
fashions not it's not just in humans I
mean have it's great tits in England
when we had milk bottle delivered on
doorsteps learned individual genius
great tits and blue tits learned to open
the milk bottles and then others watch
them and imitated and it spread
literally like an epidemic
you could actually trace this this habit
non-genetic entirely non non genetic
spreading like an epidemic like a
measles epidemic around the country
through various focal points
natural selection theoretically could
work on replicators of of that kind and
in that case we would have pneumatic
selection pneumatic evolution excuse me
my question is actually more of a
comment or observation sometimes I feel
that part of the problem with the lay
public not understanding evolution is
that we evolutionary biologists don't
always give a complete answer so for
example when asked to explain evolution
we usually go into something that
explains natural selection and give an
example like industrial melanism moss or
antibiotics or pesticides but at the end
of the day you're still got moths or
bacteria or insects and it seems like
that what we usually forget is that in
the in the process of speciation you
need to have geographic isolation
producing reproductive isolation and we
oftentimes leave that out and we
oftentimes do but I'm happy to say I
didn't yeah and you're absolutely right
and I didn't talk about peppered moths
[ __ ] I and what we need are more
examples of the speciation process than
just not yes I take your point good yes
professor Dawkins the extraordinary
similarities between ourselves and other
species that evolutionary biology helps
us understand do you think it has an
ethical implication in terms of our
treatment of non-human animals I mean in
my understanding you are not a species
list I think it does have ethical
implications if you think about the way
in which we give special treatment to
humans for example in the case of
abortion human human fetuses are treated
as babies and a lot of people think that
it's murder to abort the human fetus
whereas they quite happily Goni to cow
which of course has much more capacity
to suffer than any human fetus does now
evolution immediately has an impact on
this debate because if you think going
backwards through evolution
at some point we are connected to cows I
mean I just did it I did it earlier but
you could do it for any pair of animals
you like chimpanzees which are pretty
close to us are not given anything like
the same ethical moral legal protection
as as humans are what would we do what
would those speciesists do if a live
specimen of Lucy of Australopithecus
afarensis were to be discovered would we
have and suppose all intermediates were
available suppose there were there were
discovered relic populations in the
forests of Africa between humans and
chimpanzees all the way up to the
hairpin and back down again so close to
each other that it would be possible for
a human to brute interbreed with an
intermediate who could interbreed with
the next intermediate who could
interbreed to the next and so on who
could finally interbreed with a
chimpanzee
how would you police how would you
decide on the ethical dis discrimination
between humans and chimpanzees would we
have South African style apartheid
courts to decide whether Lucy passes for
human for example immediately now it's a
fortunate from one point of view
fortunate accident that those
intermediates are all now extinct but if
they weren't extinct we couldn't do the
sort of species it's discrimination that
we do and that that fact that they might
not be extinct should immediately give
you any uneasiness it's a pure accident
that they're extinct we ought to be able
to do do something about our morals and
our ethics taking account of the fact
that they might not have been extinct it
shouldn't this this major ethical
distinction should not depend upon the
mere accident of extinction oh hi dr.
darkins I'm a big fan and and I have
most of the elders in my family like
myself devout Christians how I could um
and they also don't really believe in
evolution how do I convince them to read
your book or at least consider evolution
without making a personal attack on
their faith it shouldn't seem like a
personal I mean it's not
a personal attack on their faith a
personal attack on somebody's faith is
often interpreted as a personal attack
on them it has a deep emotional wounding
effect
it's like saying they have an ugly face
or something like that so it's very
difficult I mean I think you can only
reasonably say look the disagreement is
a mere disagreement about cosmology
about about biology why should this be
such an immense barrier why should you
resist so strongly when you don't resist
an argument about the quality of a piece
of music or the quality of a football
team or the quality of a play or a
quality of a book but when it comes to
religion you suddenly feel all
emotionally bound up with it I should
have thought that wouldn't be beyond the
grasp of most people but it is very very
difficult and I wish you luck in your
endeavor ah you know dogs in Walt and
wolves still can interbreed looking back
at the point of my vacation and
development of new species all the
species that a define a species lose the
ability to interbreed so is there some
sort of a common process in all of life
that says once you reach a certain point
you can't interbreed yes it happens it
happens
at first when the when the chromosomes
of the two if you if you take a hybrid
like say a hybrid between a donkey
and-and-and a horse a mule or ax or a or
a hinny
the the chromosome the the genes can
still work to produce an animal and a
mule is a perfectly strong and fit
animal but when it comes to make sperms
or eggs the the chromosomes need to come
together in order to perform the process
of meiosis and if there's efficient
difference between the chromosomes as
there is between horses of donkeys then
the chromosomes can't come together in
meiosis and so the animal cannot make
gametes it can't make viable sperms or
or eggs that's the first thing that
happens the later thing that happens
the animals don't even want to mate with
each other because they look too
different or smell too different so it
is a gradual process it doesn't there's
not that there's a sudden curtain comes
down it says right you're now separate
species you can't interbreed what
happens is it's usually in geographical
isolation the ancestors of horses and
donkeys would have been split by some
kind of geographical barrier and they
would have drifted apart
or maybe been selected apart
sufficiently far that they that when
they've met again they either didn't
want to breed again or couldn't read
again in to interbreed again and that's
the point where biologists come along
and say okay they're now a different
species it is a gradual process but once
it's happened it's never reversed I
think thank you very much dr. dr. just
what I say thanks for taking our
questions thanks for great questions I
appreciate it and keeping the time
Richard Dawkins is a professor at Oxford
University he's the author of The
Selfish Gene and The God Delusion for
more information visit Richard Dawkins
net among other titles Tina Brown is the
co-founder of the day